Hey Youtubers this's Charlie. So this is gonna be my Walking Dead - Episode 9 video.
a really SOLID Tyreese episode. It is basically like
a recap of everything that's happened
and is telling us where they're going next,
that was 'what's up' with the weird
title. What happened and what's going on
that's a little too much on the nose for
me, but maybe you guys liked it.
because he went to Wiltshire Estates and
that's a big place in the comics
I'm going to explain what 'that is'. I'm going to explain that storyline the comics just
because it happened a long time ago
like season one time-line, they just skip over on the TV show
ok so just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with Wiltshire Estates
in the episode it's Noah's home he probably told them about it, that it was good place
to live, that they might be able to stay
there
and he suppose he still has family there, he doesn't know they are dead until they get there.
In the comics they actually stay there
for a while, they just happened upon it.
while is wintertime, it's really cold, they
need food, so they use it as shelter
as you imagine things go bad just like
they do in this episode
the relative composition of the group was a
little bit different Tyreese and Carol they are together
Andrea, Dale, Allen, Donna so because I
feel like they're trying to honor the
comic book story line, I feel like
that's why Rick talk to Carol on the radio
and instead of Tyreese leading it was actually Donna that died
so it's just one of the many locations
where the group stays for an extended
period of time
this episode was more of a layover though,
like a jumping off point before they go
to Washington DC
which is also another big comic book
place. Couple other big Easter eggs in the
episode like
Tyrese losing his hand as well as the
baseball bat
I don't necessarily that those were
intentional Easter eggs
they could be foreshadowing for the
future. There's this picture of Norman Reedus
holding up a cut off hand...  obviously
that's not Tyreese's  so
somebody else this season might lose a
hand. Right now Abraham is at the top of that list
caz he still has that giant wound on his hand that keeps getting worse. Okay so here we go
to top five moments
#5 Tyrese explains his
childhood it's always fun to listen to
the characters talk about themselves
Tyreese said the awesome speech about his dad. I feel that his dad
would've been a person who survived
in the apocalypse, he sounded like he knew what
was up
it's all about paying the high cost of
living, keep your eyes open
understanding what's going on, where
things are headed, face your fears which
obviously Tyreese persist to do
through the course of the episode. It
provides a nice metaphor for where the
group is at right now
like they are collectively have to
face their fears and push forward
it also kinda implies that they're going
to have to start paying attention to
what's going on in the rest the world
not just that little corner in Georgia where
they've been. When you think about it the
narrative so far, has been very
self-contained to that one state
that's why I think people are excited
about the spin-off because it's gonna be
in Los Angeles it will be like a completely
different place so you get a completely
different perspective
(quick side note) that Suburban they were
driving, the Chevy Suburban
I had several friends with dads that all
had Suburbans just like that
is just a funny thought because they are on
the road trip radioing back and forth
they clearly they have a care
being going on, that's why they were
radioing each other
moving on to #4  Welcome to
Wiltshire Estates
everyone is dead,  Noah kinda goes through
the stages of greef just like
all the other members of the group had
before,  at some point they all visited
the places where they came from and found everyone dead, so they all had that
moment that's why Tyreese was just
kind at
awkwardly shaking his head like; Yeah, Yeah.
One thing I thought was interesting
is when they were deciding that they
probably should not stay there
when they started to argue about it, and
they went outside and saw all those hacked up bodies
it looked like somebody tried to break-in
with gunfire like in with their scorch
marks
on the outside to those walls. A lot of you guys were asking me on Twitter if I thought
it might be Negaan Savior's just because
the baseball bat
I don't think it was them, I think the
people that lived there, just set those
walkers on fire (they tried to burn them) and
then the walkers just kept pounding on the
outside wall
so I don't think someone was invading with
a canon like the Governor style with
the tank
moving on to #3 In remembrance
of Beth,... Emily Kinney had that song in
the episode
I actually think that's one of her own
songs, like an actual song she wrote in
real life
it feels like something really nice from
behind the scenes that they let her do, like
we are gonna kill you, but you're
starting a music career so we give you
nice bump by putting your song in the
show
Glenn and Rick also talk a lot about her.
As if she were still alive
they would have gone there and stayed
for her. Or at least they would try to
fulfill Beth's dreaming of living in a place
like that
in a place that felt like home. Beth is
dead so it doesn't feel like home anymore
and everyone else is dead so it's
LITERALLY not home
in the comics whenever they become on
Wilshire Estates it's like a big victory
for them
the really happy it's really exciting,.. In
this episode it was really depressing
it was like a really sad moment when they
founded.
Moving on to #2 the sad train
continues as
Tyreese and Noah go back to Noah's old house. Did anyone else feel like the
minute Noah got up and ran away from
Tyrese
everything was gonna go to shit? It's
like he's violating the rules of the zombie
apocalypse movie
you never run away from the group on
your own, especially
when everything is creepy quiet. The
woman on the floor looked like his
mother
and obviously it was his twin younger
brothers that Tyreese ran a foul
It was really hard to parse what was going
through his brain when he was staring at
those pictures, when Tyreese was staring at the pictures of his younger brothers
was he looking at those, or was this
creapy look on his face;  him thinking
about
Mika and Lizzie or was he thinking
about his childhood
the minute he noticed that there were
two even though like you just knew
that yeah,  the one that's bumping the
door in the bathroom that that's the
other one
and my #1 moment obviously Tyreese
bites the dust
did he just wonder the minute you walk past
those shark jaws in the background
like,... uhhh
this is,.. this is not going to end well.
Initially I definitely didn't think he
was gonna die
I know we were all kinda wondering whether
or not he was gonna live or die,.. or what gonna
was gonna happen the minute he got bit
because there's really only a couple
things you can do, if the bite isn't that
bad
yeah you could've cut the arm off and
he would've been fine,.. but that was a
giant "shonk"
in they didn't get to him for several
minutes, so I think he died
because he lost so much blood not
because the Walker virus
and when they pulled over later in the
car I do think he'd started to turn
they pull him out and they finish him
off. Did you just feel like when they
started pulling away the car like
ohhh they may be able to salvage this, this
might be okay and jank him out of the car
it's like okay
nope this is over, this is done. It wouldn't
be a Walking Dead premiere
or finale if they didn't kill somebody
maybe Tyreese can go in Game of Thrones
in a future season
I hear they also steal a lot of actors from the wire, just in terms of cinematography
I just I can't not talk about all the
visions that Tyreese had
him talking to all the dead people, the
governor was so great, I was trying to
think a little bit in the context
up like,  eat ego superego but I think it
was simpler than that
I think it was his brain processing his
regrets, he regrets what he did for the
governor
he regrets what he did to Mika and Lizzie
even though he technically didn't do
anything to them
that was all Carol, everyone regrets Beth,
so I feel like if everyone had a version of
this scene, Beth would be in each one of theirs.
also the way they transition between real
life in his visions was really awesome
like the way Lizzy started pulling on
his arm and it turn into Andrew Lincon
Speaking of which I think the British voice on that radio was actually Andrew Lincon
I think he was the one who was
doing that, just fun behind the scenes
facts
So here's my big question for you guys, we
know they're going to Washington now
but how did you feel about Tyreese's dead, would you have rather see someone else die
did you wanted to see Noah die
I'll be honest I kinda did wanna see Noah die, I'm totally fine with
Tyler James Williams
but I don't like him as much as Chad
Coleman, so regardless of were they're
trying to take the show on the
characters
I think they wouldn't keep the Noah
character on, if he was not critical to
the back after of the plot
also I think they want to keep some
young blood in the shows like right now
Glen seems like the youngest even though
he's about the same age as Maggie
and they are not that young. So now Noah is like the noobs survivor
so expect him to get a lot like
explainer scenes from the other
characters where they teach him about
how to survive in the apocalypse
if I ever know Noah and I was going to
apprenticed anyone in the group I mean a
price stick with Darrell
or Carol, they just feel like they do the
best job of surviving on their own the
the other members the group all very
capable but feel like they need
other people to survive and Carroll feels
like she does OK on her own
and Darrell to, Darrell is kind of a loner. Let me know you guys if you though there was anything that
was just really off about the episode
and do you think that that baseball bat
is a Negan Easter Egg
I'm thinking that way way far off, so I
don't think it was meant to say,... yeah
we're going to see this person in the
next 4-5 episodes
maybe season 6 will see, maybe season 6,...
so there's a new round of giveaways starting now.
All you have to do to enter is to be
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video. I'll announce the winner in my Q&A
tomorrow
and there's like some weird subscription
problem going on with Youtube,   so
just check my Facebook or Twitter page
or my videos page if you're not
seeing the new videos show up
while you guys wait for the Q&A you can click here. I'd ranked all the episodes
from the first half of the season
and...  you can click here for the GOT
behind the scenes special
Thank you so much for watching, so lets
all high-5 I'll see you guys tomorrow.